KR: Well, the usual way that people, um, discuss
it is to talk about perfect squares first.
So, if you have studied the Pythagorean
Theorem
there's a formula that the square of the hypotenuse is the sum of the two squares of the
sides of a right triangle. So you might
ask if the, err,
the sides of a right triangle are whole
numbers
might it happen that the hypotenuse
is also a whole number.
They're called Pythagorean triples and the Greeks
figured out all of the Pythagorean Triples. Okay,
so what happened next is
I think it must have been very natural
to look at the equation
A cubed plus B cubed equals C cubed and
A to the fourth plus B fourth equals C to the fourth.
And so on. So, this is now in the realm of
algebra
and you can plug in values for 'A' and 'B'
you'll see that, err,
these equations, infinite number of
equations, seem
not to have solutions. Well, so the
story is that
Fermat was reading the text of Diophantus,
who was the Greek mathematician best known
for this type of problem.
And in the margin of his copy
of Diophantus, he wrote some marginal note
saying
that I can prove it for higher exponents
bigger than two there are no positive
integer solutions
and then famously he said but my solution
is too long to write in this margin.
And in his copy of Diophantus which
was
inherited by Fermat's son Samuel de Fermat
there are many, many marginal notes and
Samuel published a revised version,
annotated version of Diophatus's
Book in which all his father's writings
are
reproduced. And the reason that Fermat's
Last Theorem was called Fermat's Last
Theorem, is that all the previously on examined
marginal notes
proved to be correct for they were, ermm
prove to be correct or incorrect mostly
correct by
mathematicians after the
seventeenth-century and there was this
only one assertion that remained it was the last
one was hit list.
And you know again, I'm not an expert in
the history of mathematics but I think most
people
are convinced that when Fermat was
a mature mathematician he realized he
did have no proof
of this thing that he wrote in the marginal
note and in fact
later in his life he devoted a lot of
attention
to special cases of that type of equation.
It's not just the cubes but it's the cubes
the fourth powers and the fifth powers
and so on.
And Fermat himself later in his life
took care the fourth powers.
Well, the cubes
certainly must've
bothered him because after all he knew
about squares and he knew about fourth
powers and cubes,
you know, right in the middle.
BH: The theory is that
there is no solution.
There's no whole number solution.
KR: That's right.
BH: Would it have been or wouldn't it have been more exciting or more
attractive to a mathematician
to prove him wrong and to find these three
numbers that you could plug in that would
do it? Would that have been more triumphant?
KR: Well, it would have been-
would have been very exciting and would
have made lots of news.
And then the proof, so to speak, would
have been simply
on a single counter-example that would
have fit,
you know, very neatly in a newspaper
column, you known, there would have been
some story, you know.
'Mathematician in Australia finds the
first counter-example to Fermat's Last
Theorem'.  Certainly was big news either
way.
Ermm, the main thing about Fermat's Last
Theorem is that over the centuries it
gave rise to a tremendous amount
of new, and fruitful mathematics. That people
really develop new techniques to try to
solve that equation
that proved to be, you know,
infinitely versatile. BH: So a bit like going to
the moon and let[ting] them develop other
lots of other technologies along the way. This was for
going to the moon. KR: That's a-that's a fine
analogy. I mean,
you, when you formulate a problem in
mathematics no one knows
whether this problem will really be
helpful for mathematics as a general enterprise.
And, you know, for whatever reason Fermat's equation
has led to tremendous amount of- of new mathematics
KR: So, when I was a graduate student. We're
talking, you know, roughly forty years ago or
forty-five years ago. Fermat's Last Theorem
was kinda
some curiosity. Everybody knew about
the problem but no one really had any
approach to it and there was no
kinda fundamental reason why the problem
was going to have a positive solution.
And when I was a student there was a
tremendous interest in what are called
elliptic curves and it was realized
around nineteen sixty-eight, nineteen sixty-nine, nineteen seventy
by André Weil and Goro Shimura in
Princeton
who built on work of Yutaka Taniyama who was his
buddy in Tokyo in the nineteen-fifties.
Taniyama
had passed away and there was this
gradual understanding that elliptic
curves really were related
modular forms and again that was some
completely
are apparently inaccessible outstanding
conjecture
analysts thought to be incredibly hard
conjecture. And then
in the early nineteen-eighties a
mathematician came around, and I say that
literally because you know he was
sitting here in this office
his name is Gerhard Frey. At the time he
was at the University
of Saarland in Saarbrücken on
and he came-  BH: Is that a famous one? I don't know that one.
KR: Well, um, I didn't know it either and came around
and he had
the scheme for relating Fermat's Last Theorem
and the modularity conjecture. Somehow he
realized for the first time that,
um, if- if he had a solution to Fermat's equation
this would give him an elliptic curve
which apparently
could never be modular. I was a little
skeptical
because I knew that some of the things
that he said
that he needed in his argument, um, were
very hard.
Well, for me a really important thing was
in nineteen eighty-five Jean-Pierre Serre, who was
one of my mathematical heroes in Paris
sat down and kind of tried to
distill everything that had been said
about the Prey's idea
and he came out with a very clear
letter and this letter basically said if
you can prove this tiny little result
which he called epsilon because the number
in calculus, epsilon is a small number. He
said if you can prove this tiny little epsilon
then you can really show that on the
modularity conjecture, which he called
Weil at the time,
implies Fermat's Last Theorem. So, epsilon
became, for me, a holy grail because
not only was it something fairly well
encapsulated and very
clear, and this was the kind of thing that
I'd thought about before
without success but nonetheless while
thinking about yet another
problem, it occurred to me that I really
had some new information that I could
possibly bring to bear on this epsilon.
When I first did was say to myself: "What's
the simplest possible case where I can
think about this? What's the simplest
possible prediction?"
I tried to settle that. I said "Well, you
know, if you have to start somewhere.
can I-" Well, I know about this simplest
case
so I have this thing in my mind and I
thought about it,
off and on, during the academic year-
nineteen eighty-five and eighty-six.
And during this year I was teaching calculus and I was busy with things, there are,
you know, colleagues come in and they want you to be
on committees. And finally, um,
my final grades were submitted in May nineteen eighty-six and I started thinking about this
problem again, first when I was on the east
coast for a while,
going to Europe on and I found myself
in Paris. And finally I found myself
at an empty desk and on the Max Planck
Institute in Bonn
where I can just sit and think and I
thought about this
yet again - BH: Is that what you do? Do you just sit at a desk with your head and your hands, and
think, think, think, I mean - what if I was a fly on the
wall
when you were trying to crack this problem. What would I have seen? What was it looked like?
Well, it's probably not have probably had
a pad of paper in front of me and a
pencil
or a pen we didn't really have computers
quite yet although they were starting to come,
and when you visit some institute you
don't have all your stuff with you don't
have lots of books you don't have all your
paraphernalia. So I was really just kind
of sitting there
like that, and I started writing, you know.
And I-
If you look in my office you'll find
lots of old pads where I sit and write,
and, you know, a page might start what do we
know what are we trying to do
summarize the situation so far. "Let's-
let's try this",
and to my astonishment,
I was finally able to-
to cracked that problem - the simplest case of that epsilon.
BH: It's like inspiration
comes at preordained times.
Like you sit down and say, okay
for the next two hours before I make my friend Bob a hot dog,
I'm gonna have an inspiration and trying to solve the problem, and that's when it happens. It doesn't
happen on time, so you're lying on bed-
Oh it can, I mean, if you
if you think about something very
intensively then you can just carry
around with you
and you know lots of my colleagues say
that while they're swimming
had some insight or you know lots of
people say in the middle of the night
they jumped up and they said my god you
know why don't I try a minus sign instead of
instead of a plus sign
and this- this can indeed happen,
you know.
BH: Not for you though. You are an at-the-desk kind of guy?
I-I think in this particular situation I
was at the desk
I knew for the first time that
I could do something that I hadn't done before
that no one had done before. This is a
special case is this so-called
epsilon, And I kinda wrote and rewrote it just to make sure I was really right.
And finally, using a very first
Macintosh that I had access to
I typed out a letter to Barry Mazur at Harvard,
and I sent him this letter explaining what I had done.
And then I spent weeks and weeks trying to do
the general case. I couldn't see what to do and then fortunately,
there was an international congress of
mathematicians.
They occur once every four years on the campus
of UC Berkeley. So I was right here.
I came back in August
for this International Congress and Barry Mazur was there.
And on I spoke to him,
and I said Barry I sent you this letter
explaining how I did a special case, and
I really wonder, you know, what I
have to do now in the general case.
And he looked at me completely quizzically.
He said: "Well, you've already done the
general case."
and basically, he-
when he read my letter to seemed obvious to him that there was this extra little thing
you carry alone as a supplemental
object. And this extra thing which is
do the bookkeeping. And,
so we sat down at this Caffe Strada
which is at the corner of the
Berkeley campus, and we had a Cappuccino and he
kinda said well you just carry this and run with you
and I was astonished you know it's like this
amazing moment were all the sudden I realized
that in principle at least there was
no obstacle to proving this
epsilon conjecture. I mean, it like, you
know, my god, you know, it's some
special thing, you know, an angel comes down
and the light shines from the heavens
or something. So this was really quite a thing
and on since or my colleagues
were walking around the campus in this
big international congress I
kind of told, you know, a number of them
that
I have done this thing. You know of course
in beginning I was cautious I said well
I think I've done this thing, and- but
people kept
running up to me. They said was it really
true you've done epsilon? I
lived in a world and think I still do
were
my colleagues are very generous with
attributions and praise and there isn't
too much of this kinda race to be the
first to publish and
people basically- I had little fear that
someone would try to scoop me
on the other hand what was a little
worrisome
was that I hadn't written down all the
details, you know, so I kinda written down
very closely the special case. But
I hadn't kind of worried about writing
thing more generally
so what happened was that during the
year
following that, nineteen 86-87
there was a special program on algebraic
geometry and arithmetic geometry
at the Mathematical Sciences Research
Institute in Berkeley,
the MSRI. So I was up there with my callings
and
I gave lectures every week I gave
another lecture I was kinda giving like
a min course on
my proof and
when I wasn't lecturing I was furiously
typing
into the computer to try to expand and
revise
my manuscript in kinda more and more
details got put in.
There were certainly people in the
audience who were appropriately
skeptical. They asked me hard questions and I
didn't always know the answer to our
questions you know
like "How do we really know that this
thing is in
such-and-such way", and I would say well
you know this was proved in the
1960s by Grothendieck but it
isn't quite written down in the place you
expect
then I have find the argument. Well epsilon is small. It was clearly a misnomer.
And let me just get up and pull off a
reprint. Here's my article. It was published
in 1990
which really makes
are a lot of time between 1986 and 1990.
BH: How many pages?  It's like a book. Well it's a
more than a pamphlet. If you
open up this paper
on the very first or second page there's
Fermat's equation and an elliptic curve
but then they disappear. If you look at
the actual
article it's more about the
technicalities of the subject. It was a
big deal in mathematics. It got
write ups in the press,
including Science magazine
if I'm not mistaken.
You know, whenever there's a serious
announcement,
of a major theorem that gets a lot of
attention. And
people stop what they're doing to try to
see
what the basis of proof is.
BH: who called this Ribet Theorem?
you know obviously it to make that name
that is above all
other whenever addition both well the
yeah that's right so you certainly there
there's a general
aversion to naming things after yourself
very often people
give lectures and I'll say such-and-such
the room and princes the right name the
person
who on proves it and if it's a fair
amount they prove themselves
in typically right there the first
initial their last name
or something like that for all say they
don't on
they have no attribution listeners
understand all this is the fear that the
persons
is providing in this lecture. - You've done
this thing
which is important if you have a bridge
between two things which
no other which also Granja. - Well that's
right so the
um what what I when I showed was that
this modularity
conjecture which was thought to be was
was felt to be true
but um wasn't expected to be provable
I show that that thing actually implies
there was less there
I think the main takeaway from my
theorem was
that since the very conjecture
short on the OMA was likely to be true
that now you should think that for miles
last year it was likely to be true
for example it probably wouldn't have
been a really
good idea to spend a lot of computing
power looking for a counterexample
farrell's less there well as anyone else
who's in the room
well I was the whole thing so any Wells
you know coursing
came around a few times I guess but
basically he was holed up in his attic
and I didn't know that and I think most
people didn't know that
so he was on I mean it's his I'm
it's a statement that he was
certainly intrigued by Fermat's last theorem
as a child and then as soon as he heard
about this
Ridge he decided to try to prove the
modularity theorem
because of its relation to the Fermat's last theorem.
so was it is a sort of the situation that Andrew Wiles
wanted to prove Fermat's last theorem by any means possible he given him the means
that's what he says I mean if this is
surprising to me because
modularity theorem by itself is a
tremendous price
and you know it seems kind of strange
that you needed
the motivation to Fermats to go and
try to prove it if you thought that
there was some way
side well anyway that's that's that's
that's what he says
yet we were all together meaning kinda
lots of people in the subject in a
conference in Cambridge England
in June 1993 and usually go to a
conference and you see the list speakers
and you know you speaker has an hour
and the thing and then set up so that
Andrew Wiles had three hours
I'm so here's the organizers he said I
have something I want to discuss it will
take me three hours and I like those
slots
I said okay from and then
in the first lecture you could see he
was proving
He was trying to prove the modularity
of some class elliptic curves but
the class elliptic curves at least in
the first lecture had
no intersection with the class that you
needed for Fermat's last theorem
within the second lecture got a lot
closer and
it became more and more parents have
people at the conference
third lecture he was going to be able to
do enough
to get fair was last year the crowd was
growing so love the mathematicians
you know brought their colleagues who
happen to be in Cambridge in
you know some other family members and
I think there was a little doubt that he
would announce approval for was left
there I'm so I
can i sat in the front row center and
brought my camera and snap the picture of him
I wasn't another moment when you know
those cuts time stop
and when I first realized what was going
to happen ..
and then you know when it actually did
happen there was this some
frends of activity I mean the director
love of the Isaac Newton Institute
where these lectures were held on
had ordered a case a Napa Valley brute
champagne
for the end the lecture is after the
lecture we came out into the
you know common area only is all the
champagne flutes were
produced in his bottle started popping
you know this is kinda really an amazing
thing between that time when you-
originally published a paper and this
lecture it was a cold or write you a
nasty lol nah to work
not a word you know it i no idea what he
was doing
on you he whole who absolutely
he was so he was a a friend and a
colleague I first met him when he was a
graduate student in Cambridge
and in fact when I first came to
berkeley the first year that I was here
he was one of the first people that I
invited came to spend a week and gave a
lecture to
on do you that delight he kept a secret
that make a surprise I
to this day you battle by I'm using a
little collegiate
you're telling me when you thought you
open your running around telling
everyone
NEC said well it's very unusual behavior
and the you know you can say in
retrospect that it was really
um justified because he was afraid that
people would kind of jump all over it
because %uh the important so
the modularity conjecture and fair I was
last there
on button he did not on
tell me what he was doing he did from
confide in to this calling to princeton
as he was giving
is graduate course where he was working
out the ideas
that on were instrumental in this paper
I think it was only a few days later
that I got a copy of this manuscript
and the manuscript was very thick
nose like 300 pages from
single space you know typeset by
test mathematics typesetting program and
on we were supposed to
be the referee is on
looking at different parts of the paper
and I was assigned to a par
that be turn out to be problem-free arm
and I'm the cats look at a park but
turn out to have problems a problem was
there shattering
for you a do you like that doesn't make
you think this is good
I like the reader a lot about it really
deflating up to I have
champagne mean finding the problem well
from want more of the aspects of the
whole thing is that I had gone out
pretty for a limb
from telling everybody that Andrew Wiles
improve this thing
on in the way that started was that
when the New York Times first heard
about his announcement may ask to speak
to him and returns me and said
and you know you speak to Gina Kolata so
I went
and on went upstairs and
spoke to her for a very long time
explaining the whole thing
and then I'm somehow the media kept
calling me
because it was understood from that
somehow I was is designated spokesperson
so I nice spent the entire summer
I'm lecturing about his theorem
and
I'm fielding phone calls from I'm the
press
hello for was announcement cast
oh I think it was like two weeks what
happens in mathematics is if if you have
a proof that seems to really be
on seems to have a lot or
from internal logic
to it and there's something that's wrong
with the proof
your immediate reaction is to say well
you know this is just some technical
problem that I need to fix
and I think that are Andrew Wiles when
he
found out about the gap arm expected
that you would be able to repair insured
or
so it really took a while before there
was some
realization on his part that this was a
serious problem
couldn't be fixed on immediately just by
their
tools improper if you love the person
who was taking all the calls from the
press
whatever reason did that mean you will
you are contacting
and while get updates on the game
because my i don't know what to tell
them what
we call him but those you want to say it
was a
he gone right not especially Inc he kind
of went dark
he was working on on mathematics and
I wasn't wasn't getting a lot of
information out of him at that time
you know it was all poison about right i
mean
I'm wasn't clear whether or not this
will get repaired or not
and then you know wonderfully it turned
out that there was
this so repair to the proof
from release in completely new insight
actually by Andrew Wiles and Richard
Taylor
who work together over the summer and
this will be the summer
1994 and they
had a or preprint out
in in the fall 1994 really explain their
new method in which is now
call Taylor Wiles method and that
really I'm circumvented a lot or the
more complicated arguments in the
original
preprint and the two articles were
published together
on the following summer which is a
summer 1995 in the annals of mathematics
it was a relief but it was it was not
our
kinda joyous relief you know and Richard
Taylor came to me one day
again MSRI where I happen to be in
fall far 1994 any sand
we have some good news for you and then
on the next day and make up in this
paper so that was kinda very good
and you know I don't remember there
being
a huge celebration on the moment
the releases that reprint been just
kinda gradually build people understand
that the proof is complete
and then there was a very large
instructional conference at Boston
University in summer
1995 different people got up and explain
the different
elements approve well it was a fabulous
pieces mathematics
arm as impressed arm with by
what what I did and presses I am by my
my own were coming
I'm even much more impressed by what
they did
on they had some really knew inside and
this inside has I'm percolated through
our whole subject for the last twenty
years arm
one way to say what they did is they
showed
that somehow modularity is contagious
in the sense that if you have something
that hope has a little pieces that the
modular
you can parlay that into modularity over
forty first evolved Wiles was
obviously intensely driven to do this he
was
really motivated and he said you know
I'm gonna do this one way or another
and me brought in all sorts a
different techniques that hadn't been
related
on to the the problem before
on what some what's amazing for example
there's a whole subject an algebraic
geometry call deformation theory
that was going on when I was a graduate
student that I didn't learn
I thought that was really far removed
from anything involving
elliptic curves and on in
the years before wells announcement
Harry Mazer
had developed this new technique of
deformation theory in gallery
presentations and it turned out to be
exactly what
Wiles needed the language in the
techniques the median
for his discussion on and so
you know something that seems to be far
away technically turn out to be crucial
well I think I'm you know just
informally everyone refer to it as the
Fermat's last theorem
but in fact when you when you look at
the article just like my article was
something internal to
on series modular forms and get our
presentations and Wiles article in my
article share
the trait that for was a question covers
exactly once in the article in the
beginning
and then you get down to the real stuff
on very happy with the
recognition that I've gotten and I
very proud of what I did and be I
when students come and my classes they
may know about my
role for Fermat's last theorem. A lot of them have seen the
video that was broadcast on over and BBC
and a I think you know if you do
something very very very very famous and
you have an encore problem
where people saying you know what great
thing you're going to do next
and I try to be on more or less a normal
guy
and
not you know walk around with angels on
your shoulder
britt to rediscover what FAMAS proof
might it be
is that they have widely-helds that he
had done it already disclaim lot
was he telling the truth ? I think by the
time we get to 20th century it's quite
clear
that this is an incredibly complex problem.